in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jim and
Susie are with us hey how are you
we are officially better than we deserve
Dave I like officially that'll work what
do you guys live West Des Moines Iowa
fun and well thank you for being in
Nashville and here to do your debt-free
scream yes much of you paid off we've
paid off fifty six thousand nine hundred
and seventy four dollars and 61 cents
and we also cash flowed twenty-seven
thousand eight hundred and thirty four
dollars and 53 cents during that same
time what was the cash flowing a wedding
five semesters of tuition in books some
glasses some dental work lots of life
Wow very cool okay and how long did this
take you three years and eight months
alright and making what kind of money
during the three years and eight months
we started off at forty thousand and now
a hundred and nine thousand that's a
little change so what do you all do for
a living I'm the finance and benefits
manager for a non-profit I'm a computer
systems engineer so what happened to
your income I had an internship and then
graduated college and then upon
graduating and I had a full-time job
ready for me big boy big money I like it
that'll work I like it cool so what
happened three point eight years ago
that caused your three years and eight
months ago that caused this journey to
begin tell me about your journey well we
got married and that kind of started us
off jim was in college at the time so it
wasn't really on the plan I was on the
plan and when we got married we just
went ahead forward again so that's
simple yeah so you were already doing
Dave Ramsey get out of debt debt
snowball whatever yeah I had paid off
$18,000 by the time we got married and
then when we got married we pretty much
doubled what we had again with his
student loans which was three months
four years and eight months ago yes we
got married okay so Jim this this crazy
woman that you're marrying is out here
selling everything working like crazy
marking off checking off boxes getting
out of debt and you walk into this and
what did you say I was on board when I
was starting school or in between
Community College and my four-year my
brother was going through a hard time
and
got hooked up through a bank or through
his church and when they were
coordinating I was babysitting so I was
hearing it from the other room oh ma and
that was kind of how my family got
started on the plan and then as I got
older I learned what it was about and
then going through school my first
semester on my four-year degree
there was a checkbox that made a huge
difference on whether it was fully paid
for tuition or if I had to pay for most
of it and so there was a paperwork
mistake and we got that figured out and
that kind of dumped a bunch of
unexpected debt on student loans on me
and then I was just like I'm gonna fight
this and work through school so I've
held a job pretty much since the first
month aizen back to school Wow good for
you very cool the good news is you got a
great income so you were able to dig out
of this pretty quick so what do you tell
people I mean a newly married couple
pays off fifty-seven thousand dollars in
cash flows another twenty eight what do
you tell people the secret to doing this
is to winning well the first five
minutes after we were married
down in the reception hall people were
asking so you're buying are you gonna
buy a home we're like no that's not our
plan yet during the reception
these people have no mercy or sense
and then the real key for me is just be
passionate about it and after the last
few months have been really hard because
it started to feel like a physical
sickness because the the amount of money
that we were throwing at selling may to
kick her out of our house was I didn't
see a dime of my income for that whole
time and that's just it makes you sick
to see all these opportunities where you
could help people and just make a
difference is actually going to someone
you owe your money so it's so sick that
you'll never go back yeah yeah I hear
you very cool what about you Suzie what
do you think the secrets are um I think
secrets are really just real sacrifice
not just not buying stuff not going to
Target or whatever but like really
really making a difference
um Jim has been working in job his big
boy job is really stressful and it's
been it's been really hard for him but
he stayed there because that money was
getting us out of debt that much faster
um I really have appreciated that
sacrifice but also things like our air
conditioning broke in the truck last
summer and we still haven't fixed it
because it's gonna be super expensive
and Jim drove the truck all last summer
in this summer in Iowa which is pretty
humid with no a/c
joyfull yeah so now you get the truck
dadgum truck AC yeah first order of
business now that we're out of debt well
congratulations you two very very proud
of you absolute rock stars very very
well done
that is the way to start your marriage
learning to work together learning to
team up on an in a common enemy a foe
and that foes name was Sally Mae we
kicked her butt out of the house you
gave her her eviction notice yeah I
liked it very cool
Jim and Susie Des Moines Iowa fifty
seven thousand dollars paid off three
years and eight months making 40 up to
109 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
yes I love it
yes next thing is we're gonna have you
trained on how to do it that free scream
that was good
yeah you cared that's awesome